parallèlement assez référendum qui sont
encore organisés pour quelques heures la
mobilisation elle se poursuit
mobilisation partielle annoncée par
Vladimir Poutine et on a ce chiffre qui
nous parvient alors rares sont les
communications en termes de en terme de
chiffres de la part des Russes
261000 russes auraient fuit le pays
depuis l'annonce du chef du Kremlin tout
à fait 261 000 russes on a la Géorgie
également qui vient de dire que le
nombre de Russes qui ont passé sa
frontière à doubler et passer à 30 000
par jour ce sont des chiffres qui sont
conséquents c'est même assez symbolique
que ce soit 261 000 hommes qui ont fui
qui a été donné étant donné que le but
de Moscou c'est d'en recruter toi
quasiment le même nombre pour aller pour
aller se battre en Ukraine il faut
simplement rappeler qu'on est dans un
pays de 140 millions d'habitants donc à
peu près 70 millions d'hommes ça fait
0,37% des hommes russes qui ont franchi
la frontière on n'est pas du tout dans
les mêmes proportions de l'Exode qu'on
peut voir en Ukraine néanmoins ce qui
peut inquiéter le régime de Vladimir
Poutine ce sont les raisons qui ont
poussé ces hommes à quitter la Russie ça
n'est pas tant l'opposition de principe
à la guerre en Ukraine puisque les gens
qui étaient opposés dès le départ à la
guerre en Ukraine eux ils sont déjà
partis mais c'est plutôt un sentiment
d'injustice parce qu'ils ont
l'impression que ce sont toujours les
mêmes c'est à dire les gens des des
provinces minoritaires du Daguestan de
Sibérie des classes populaires qui sont
envoyées et pas les par exemple les les
dignitaires du régime leurs enfants les
fonctionnaires c'est ce qu'on entend
dans les manifestations il y a le manque
de confiance vis-à-vis du zèle de
l'administration qui appliquent un peu
l'ordre de mobilisation de manière
excessive en recrutant des retraités des
malades il y a aussi et je finirai
là-dessus quelque chose qui est un petit
peu profond mais qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que dans le putinisme il y a un
pacte social qui fait qu'il est admis
que la population laisse les gouvernants
gérer le pays comme ils veulent quitte à
truquer les élections sans Richir etc
tant que ces gouvernants ne se mêlent
pas de la ne viennent pas interférer
dans la vie quotidienne et dans la vie
privée des rues c'est cette mobilisation
et bien elle a elle a cassé ce consensus
elle a cassé ce pacte social et ça
effectivement ça peut être dangereux
peut-être pas forcément à court terme vu
les chiffres mais à moyen terme pour le
régime de Vladimir Poutine merci
beaucoup